NBC News correspondent Katie tor wrote a
book called unbelievable my front row
seat to the craziest campaign in
American history of course about her
coverage of Donald Trump's candidacy
last year and Donald Trump according to
the book last year during the campaign
gave Katie tor an unwelcome kiss on the
cheek during the campaign tour said
Trump kissed her before an appearance on
MSNBC's Morning Joe she said quote
before I know what's happening
his hands are on my shoulders and his
lips are on my cheek my eyes widen my
body freezes my heart stops mm-hmm I'm
getting the chills just from reading
this it's making me have to clear my
throat
Trump was apparently regularly sort of a
round Katie tore privately even though
he was targeting her publicly during the
campaign he would refer to her as little
Katie not exactly a sign of respect from
a candidate to a member of media
he called her a third-rate reporter
during a rally and Katie tore says that
after that incident the Secret Service
actually walked her to her car because
they feared for her safety when Trump
identified her editor at a rally as a
third-rate reporter of course after news
of Katie tors assertion in her book
leaked Donald Trump took to Twitter we
don't know for sure that this tweet
refers to what Katie tor wrote in the
book but it appears to he wrote
fascinating to watch people writing
books and major articles about me and
yet they know nothing about me and have
zero access a few thoughts here okay
number one if you look on the you know
indie catacombs and bowels of the
internet this is fake Katie tor is a
liar she's making it up really if this
is all Donald Trump did given Trump's
history I would say Katie tor is lucky
that all he did was give her an unwanted
kiss on the cheek this is exactly what
Trump says he does right on the access
hollywood tapes Trump says he just
kisses women when he wants that they let
him because of who he is and if you
gotta grab him by the
you know what he will secondly how
shocking is it that unwanted advances
are touching or whatever from the
President of the United States barely
even register because of the broader
context of what's going on in a normal
world you'd think that such an
allegation would be a huge huge deal but
yeah there were some stories about this
but it's not even making a big splash
because number one it's just another
woman on the list of what close to two
dozen at this point that have made
similar assertions and in addition to
that there's so many other scandals
going on in perpetuity you know in other
countries it's not unusual for two
people to meet and they exchange kisses
on the cheek I mean we see that around
the world Argentina and Argentina but
you know it's just not typically a
custom here now and if it is done it's
not done in any sort of sexual or
romantic way yeah with Donald Trump I
mean we can't give him that benefit of
the doubt because his words contradict
that yeah and the the other aspect of
this for people saying it's just fake is
what accusations have been made about
Donald Trump that have been proven false
I mean in all of this it's like Oh what
Trump's lying about his charitable
donations turns out to be true more and
more of the Russian dossier initially
unproven turns out to be true
there's just no trend of all of these
incorrect allegations being made about
Donald Trump and lastly I do think Trump
is sort of off sexually but I think a
lot of this stuff is is even the
language of grabbing by the [ __ ] it's
more about dominance than it is about
sex right it's more about Trump being in
control and we get insight into that
from something Katy tor said Katy tour
said when Trump kissed her
the first thing she thought of was I
hope the cameras didn't see it because
my bosses will not take me seriously
she's probably right that if her bosses
knew Trump kissed her it wouldn't be
good for her career-wise it would raise
questions about her journalistic ethics
or appearance or whatever even though it
would be effectively punishing her for
having been the recipient of unwanted
advances from Trump she's right about
that and I think that goes to show that
there's a dominance aspect to this that
seems to be what is motivating Trump in
some way and it's like Trump knows
that the kiss is unwanted to which is an
extra layer there because it is about
dominance I mean in that Access
Hollywood tape he said that he doesn't
even weight implying that he doesn't
even wait for consent and I guess most
damning part of that no doubt about it
and listen Trump is a vile guy right
like a genuinely repulsive person I was
thinking of the entire who would you
rather have a beer with thing remember
that would you rather have a beer with
bush or Obama would you rather have a
beer with Obama or Romney actually well
Romney's a Mormon he supposedly doesn't
drink so that's not a good example Trump
actually supposedly doesn't drink either
but the idea of it right can anyone
really imagine just hanging out with
Trump and I'm reminded of the video of
Trump with the French president where
they're sitting there watching a live
marching band and the band breaks into a
Daft Punk cover in marching band style
and Trump just looks miserable like he
doesn't get it Emmanuel macron is
laughing he gets it even I don't
recognize the song you get oh this is
interesting this is cool Trump just
doesn't get it like it seems miserable
to be around him and Melania certainly
seems miserable to be around him this is
just not a person I have any interest in
being around and that's why I totally
get you know the victims of Hurricane
Harvey saying yeah we're not interested
in meeting with Donald Trump just yeah
we're good it's not necessary the
parents of Heather hair who was run over
in that horrible Charlottesville
incident saying yeah we have no interest
in meeting with Donald Trump I get it I
don't want to be around the guy either
you don't know what he's gonna say to if
he just says well it's one of the same
with the neo-nazis is the anti-fog group
could make it worse yeah Heather hey or
she was a great person just like the
great people on the other side as well
just absolutely horrible the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad